>> Good afternoon all. So, today
I'm here to speak about rather
emotional and
a very serious aspect of
ones life, which is death.
So, we bring back dead people
to life. I was joking.
Okay. So, firstly thanks a lot,
the Microsoft and some other
ventures for having us here.
It's really a privilege to
be part of this workshop.
So, I'm Shruthi Reddy,
the founder of
Anthyesti Foundation.
For after having worked
for about 10 years
behind the computer,
Java programming, coding,
I decided to call
it quits and then
my pension for social sector
had made me jump into
this entrepreneurship.
So the project Amrit,
what exactly does Amrit mean?
Amrit means, Amrit is
a Sanskrit word which
means immortal.
So through this project we aim to
say that every human being
can become immortal only
because he's got the chance
to live another life,
that is through organ donations.
So during my tenure that is
where I met Mr. [inaudible] .
He's also very equally
passionate person
about organ donation
and he comes with
about 18 years of experience
in the pharmaceutical industry.
So, looking at the statistics,
can you all believe
that in India only
0.08 per million population
actually donated organs?
It's not even like one percent
and looking at the
statistics over here,
in 2014 only 0.84 percent
of the road traffic accidents
got connoted to organ donations,
2015, 2016, 2017.
Yes, there is an improvement
but then there
is very mild improvement.
No wide road traffic accidents
are specifically
of our interest because most of
these road traffic accidents
actually result in
something known
as brain debts and brain debts
are the most cases wherein we
can do lot of
solid organ transplants.
Just have a look at
a 2018 requirements.
Three lack kidney transplants,
40,000 heart transplants and
25,000 liver transplants and
it's a very sad state to
say that out of this probably in
kidney transplant
just about two percent
will get their
kidneys transplanted.
Here it is about 0.1 percent in
cardiac and 0.2 percent
in liver transplants.
So we Antyesti Foundation
we're relatively new NGO.
It's been about one-and-half
year and we have been
working extensively
at the colleges in
the corporate level trying to
do campaigning about
what organ donation is,
helping people remove the myth
about organ donation.
So in the process we have
collected about a
thousand plus pledges,
impacted about 1200 plus
colleges and corporates
and we're also successful in
training 50-plus
transplant coordinators.
Now, talking about what
exactly are the problems,
why do we have such
abysmally low rates
of organ donation?
Firstly is the public attitude
towards organ donation.
So if you really go to
public and then you say that
are you interested in doing
organ donations
after a person dies?
Speculatively, no
because they've got
so many myths about
organ donation.
A person would say that oh
no if you take my eyes in
this life probably I might
be born blind in next life.
Yes, this is truth. This
is what people say to us.
Then step two is coming about
consent for organ donation.
So let me just explain
the meaning of organ donation.
Organ donation is
a process wherein when
a person is still alive with
his own consent he
can get his organs
to the needy or when
the person is not alive,
he's dead, then
with the consent of
his relatives then he
can donate the organs.
So step two where we
tackle is about we need
to get consent of relatives
of organ donation.
So let's say that I have
pledged for my organs and if
I die a brain-death but
if my relatives
aren't aware of it,
if my [inaudible] do not know
about it then the hospital
cannot do anything to
harvest my organs.
The next step is the
brain-death identification
and certification.
So if you see this
there's actually
a lot that goes into
identifying brain-death
and certifying.
In India the process
says that there are
about four doctors from
various backgrounds who have
to come at an interval of
six hours each and then
identify the brain death.
After this three major
hurdles are crossed,
we are not yet game because there
is lot more that comes
from adequate hospital
infrastructure.
So if the hospitals do not have
a very good organ retrieval team
then it's a waste.
After that, in spite of having
a good organ retrieval team,
we need to have got logistics for
the transport of organs
to the recipient's body.
So there were cases where
organs have actually traveled
like thousand kilometers and
they were fitted into
the recipient's body.
This is what actually leads to
a successful organ transplant.
So, yes, each and
every point in this
explains leads to one
successful organ transplant.
So talking about
the first point, that is,
how can AI machine
or learning actually
implement an overall positive
public attitude in
the general public?
Because so far we've been
reaching out to colleges,
corporates personally but
I think if you really
implement the programs online
and leverage social media,
for let say we are creating
online recorded webinars
and which is going to
the public etc and then we
are able to record the pledges.
Once we know
a particular pledgee,
using Facebook data analytics
probably we can get to know about
the cultural preferences,
their dataset,
their behavioral preferences
and in turn start using
this customized audiences
marketing in order to market
to the relatives and to
their total communities.
So this is one place where we
can possibly use social media to
a lot extent for
the mass awareness
campaigns which I
guess nobody in India is doing
regarding to organ donation.
So can we convert pledge data
into real donations?
Yes, this is one of
the major aspect how
we can use social media
for doing it.
Now this is again
another startling fact.
There are at least 10
to 12 patients who are
admitted in ICU and are
declared brain-dead.
So, can I have a show
of hands as to
how many over here know
what a brain death is.
Okay, that's like
just 10 percent.
Okay, [inaudible] you want
to say about brain death?
>> Yeah. First of all,
I would just like to, thanks.
Organ donation we need to be
a little bit more specific.
Here we are talking
about the solid organs.
Solid organs means
the heart, the liver,
the kidneys which are extremely
vital to human being's life.
There are certain tissue also
which fall into
this particular garment
of organ donation like the
cornea's, it's a tissue.
Skin, it's a tissue.
There are some stem
cell transplantations
also which requires for
a hematopoietic patient.
So there are different kinds
of category of organ donation.
Why I need clarity over here is
because solid organs
are something which
a patient is in
the death bed waiting
for the next day maybe
he will be alive or not.
In a situation where
the extreme amount of
seriousness of
the patient is there,
how many of us has
actually witnessed
a patient who is in
dialysis for five years?
Now, every month
the patient goes to
the hospital and the doctor only
tells that you know
you were in stage 3A,
now you're in stage 3B.
So, some a technology,
some medical information
has been incorporated.
Some seriousness is being
propagated to the next level.
So, organ donation and
the solid organ donation
the seriousness
and some kind of intelligence,
if we can marry it,
it becomes more meaningful.
Second part,
the brainstem did part.
The brain is majorly
of the cortex,
but there is a stem also.
Now, if for certain reason,
the stem is not active,
it is legally as per medically
it is a dead person.
It is an irreversible death.
A patient who's in a coma
is a reversible one.
So, his stem is not dead.
Maybe the other functions are
not actually properly working,
but the brainstem is
a clear cut case of death.
Now, this awareness is
mostly not there
with common people.
I have been interacting
and very closely and
working with a lot of doctors
of the medical fraternity.
Especially the ideals as
well as the intensivist.
Even they are a little bit
reluctant that no,
I don't have this kind
of technology,
which can really tell me that
this patient is
totally brain-dead.
Tomorrow, somebody will
catch hold of me and tell
me what is the proof that
this patient was brain dead.
So, there are certain things in
medical record which
they practice.
Every six hours as
[inaudible] told they
check it with
a committee of doctors,
in an unbiased way,
and finally sign.
What are laundry list of
tests which confirms that
the patient is brainstem dead?
>>So, yeah. So
actually a majority of
road traffic accidents
lead to brainstem dead.
So, in brain death
cases what people
lose their discipline
put on a ventilator,
and all the other organs are
actually kept ventilated.
So, although the brain is dead,
the other organs there is
proper oxygen supply and
blood supplies there,
and each organ has
got its own life to
get transplanted like for example
the heart at the max you
got four to six hours.
So, between this
four to six hours,
the organ needs to
be removed from
the donor and put
into the recipient.
That is crossing all those five
or six levels whatever
I have explained.
Kidneys are the maximum
can be held what
24 hours to 48 hours for
kidney which is again,
probably a sad state that kidney
one-off organ that can be
removed from a living person.
So, that is where
the trafficking happens.
A lot of exploitation happens.
Same with the liver as well.
Liver and kidneys as well,
living donations happen.
So, now coming to can we increase
success rate of PAC declarations
into transplants?
I think yes. Definitely, using
technology and
mobile applications, yes.
One such being notifications.
So, what if our
brainstem dead donor
is identified in an ICU?
And, all people who were
involved in the
stakeholder change,
given notifications that there's
possible brain-dead case,
come on now act.
So, if you get into
what shooting at
a mechanism and the status
is being populated from state
one to state two to state four,
the complete time lag
whatever it is dead,
from the harvesting
of the organ to
putting the organ into
the recipient's body
that is totally eliminated,
and what the other advantage?
Like if you want to
collect this data,
any reason and give you
a couple of states which
are having the
transplant waiting list.
So, the more and more we
have successful transplant,
the more and more they would
increase the prediction of,
what kind of good news
will we match with
what kind of patterns?
Or who is possible recipient
of this kind of liver?
Yeah, a guidebook and
the green channel.
So generally,
not all surgeons have
the ability to do transplants.
So, there is
a specific guidebook,
which is right now
being spoken about by
the NGOs et cetera,
who are already
doing a transplants.
So, that can be also part
of the technology but,
and the green channel.
So, as I told that this there
is lots of logistics in
world specifically in
the transport of organs.
If the police et cetera,
they already trained
in the process
that there is an organ that
needs to be transported,
and hence ME green corridors,
that's making life easy for
the organ to be transported.
So, this is a little bit of
dataset which [inaudible]
want to speak about.
>> Yeah. There is a lot of
mapping which we have done.
Basically, this slide is
basically on the
road traffic accidents,
which occur across
the year in India.
Let me tell you, it is
more than 1.5 plus,
and these are all deaths
which are reported as
per the data and statistics
taken from different sources.
Now, I have done a little bit of
division across states also,
where the vulnerability of
these accidents in
highways are more.
Now, what happens in
a practical situation?
There is a highway, and there is
a accident, fatal accident.
Once the patient is taken to
some emergency department
of a hospital,
the patient is half
dead, and more so,
if there is a head injury,
and the head injury cases
are mostly the cases
where the brainstem death
is been a chance and probability.
So, that's the interest area.
How we can map it through
technology first.
Second, there is another very
interesting observation,
18 to 45 is
the age in which
the maximum brain death
due to road accidents
has happened.
Now, 60 year old person
declared brain-dead cannot donate
his heart because medically,
it is not allowed, more than 45.
So, that particular productive
time of age where
there is an actual road
a traffic accident,
and it is factual,
and the person is brain
dead, and basically,
eight organs from
that particular body
can be retrieved properly,
harvested, and eight people
can live from those organs.
I strongly believe that
some kind of a technology and
information can really make
this process more spread out,
and more reaching to
most of the people,
especially the reporting part.
Mostly it happens like,
this with this data which
I've collected from a lot of
intensivist across hospitals.
They say that even if
the final patient comes
to them to the ITU,
already there are
three to four layers of
methods through which time
has been already occupied.
So, they do not get,
I enter here and enters
directly to the ITU.
There is an emergency departments,
it has to be informed.
They are transplant coordinators
which needs to be informed.
They're grief counselors
There is a committee of
four or five doctors
including the superintendent
of the hospital,
who has to come and play
a very important role,
and finally,
this intensivist also tells
me that what is
my interests out of it,
even if I declare a brain dead.
I will get nothing.
The only thing
you will get is some certain
amount of maybe recognition,
and fame into
his peers colleagues.
That he's the person who
has done certain thing,
which is out of the way,
and more so let me be
also very practical with
my last 10 years of
experience into Dr. speaking.
They have learned
some different text book
unambiguous, and graduation.
Now, suddenly brain dead
is something array.
This is I'm not red,
hair red or certified or
something in my college life.
So, why should I go buy it?
What is the lottery?
Should I get involved
into it or shouldn't I?
Is the hospital
authority behind me?
Are the legal things behind me?
Yeah, I know the
benefit that four,
five people can be
saved by this process.
But how am I really
going to work about it?
So, a lot of help can be
actually given in terms
of a function technology
to these doctors,
who are eager, maybe
a fence sitter.
They can cross
the fence and come into
the real project of
brainstem dead declaration.
This is where the
things are, two,
three things today
when we were coming to
the airport to our this venue,
some very good view cropped up
suddenly as we were
working on Bengal
organization society,
and we belongs Calcutta.
There was a brainstem
death declared,
and the heart was
actually transplanted to
a needy person who was lying on
the brain dead in Fortis
hospital today in Calvinta.
So, why are you taught to talk
about heart so emotionally,
as well as so passionately is
that heart is one such organ,
which cannot be manufactured in
some lab or cannot
be live donated.
We have two kidneys.
So, one can be donated to
our nearest dearest ones.
A portion of the liver can
be donated to the needy one.
What about the person
who requires a heart?
So, whenever I was also
discussing with Sudiman,
that whenever there
is a heart donation
that signifies that
something is moving in
the positive direction
of organ donation,
and actual brainstem
death, and its benefits.
So, this is a classical example.
So, I'm very excited
about these data.
Keep on collecting it, and
keep it in some kind of a base,
which can we definitely
churned out to
something positive,
to move forward,
and make a real impact into
the arena of organ donation.
>> So, let end this presentation
with a small note.
In the past two years
of I've been working
with end-stage renal
disease patients,
guys, it's our life at all.
It's like day in and day out,
they have to go
beyond the machine,
undergoing dialysis, and then
go back home lead a life.
At least, dialysis patients
can be given a little bit of
probably a good luck, I can say,
but look, if you think about
people who need a heart.
It's like they are
bedridden totally.
They are under [inaudible] because
a heart can't function properly,
there's an artificial mechanism,
which is actually pumping blood
through, like throughout.
If you see the number of
deaths that's happening easily by
having proper awareness and
by utilizing proper mechanisms,
we can convert those deaths
into life of new people.
So, rather than burying
the organs or rather
than burning the organs,
I think this is one of
the best way how we
can give people
a new life. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> So, thank you, team.
Guys open up for
any questions. Yes, please.
>> I had a quick question. I am
not very familiar with there is
a National Donor Database
and especially now
with RR and all.
We expect to have a consent
framework where somebody,
let's say like me can walk up,
volunteer as a donor, put
my RR authentication and just
give you whatever you need for
later on matching and whatnot.
So, is there's something
like that in the works or?
>> Yes. It is there.
It's there in place.
>> Even if, sir, if It is there,
how does it help you?
If even if I pledge today?
So, when I'm dying
of a road accident,
how does it matter?
>> Not to me, for example,
if you will start with consent,
such that it takes you three
hours to locate a relative,
so, who will give the consent?
>> So, exactly. Here it is.
Now, for the see,
today it was just
like a pledge form.
Where it can be noted and
put it in some database.
So, certain amount of
information is already
captured regarding
who has placed it,
but when the person is
actually on the deathbed,
none of the relatives
come and say, "No, no,
no, no pledging, pledging,
[inaudible] I don't know."
>> So, it's a law? It's a law.
>> It's a legal process?
>> Yes, actually it is a law,
which is why we have to
have legal awareness.
>> So now, there
is a specific role
about how we can reach
out to the common public.
Yes, we can discuss it
inside the family
while having a dinner.
That today I've done a noble job.
I have placed my organs.
My mother told, "What?"
She never heard about it?
My wife does, no it doesn't
feel very encouraging.
See, this is the first reaction,
which comes from
that extremely nearer dear ones.
So, just imagine what will happen
when actually we
reach that kind of
a position when somebody is dying
and some transplant coordinator
walks down and asks,
that since it is a brain-dead,
can you donate your kin's organs?
It becomes rather a kind of
a very messy and murky situation.
Let me tell you, but yes.
There are kind of things,
which can be done within
this particular identifying
of brain-dead and
actually declaring it,
and where a little bit
of technology,
information, database,
can help out.
I have a database
of certain donors
who have actually after
brain-dead have donated,
means their nearest kin
have donated.
That means there was
sudden amount of
awareness from some part
of the society,
which had actually
gave them an idea.
Yes, this can be done and
it's a noble thought.
So, if we can help the society
with this kind of a thing.
So, even if the doctor
continuously presses
upon the patient,
who is already dead,
the patient slowly starts,
"Your kidney [inaudible]."
He wants to sell
my patient's kidney now.
So, immediately the doctor
will keep you, keep it away.
Now, there is a rule of
transplant donator,
grief counselors.
Why the Tamil Nadu model
has become so promising.
Why the Maharashtra model
is doing so good?
Why the Delhi model
Why the PGIMER Chandigarh model
is doing so good?
So, Nadu is also capturing
some data regarding this,
[inaudible] Foundation
is also captured,
even [inaudible] Foundation has
captured all the pledge forms.
We have a database already ready,
but it needs to be gathered in
one particular platform
just like a Cloud.
So, if there is a heart,
which is required in Bangalore
and there is a
brain-dead in Calcutta,
it can be immediately done within
the first four hours
by green corridor,
by flight, immediately
inside that OT chamber.
So, this kind of a data should
be there in the system,
which will propel this kind
of organ donation
to the next level.
>> Of what pledgee,
I strongly believe
that the probability
of the pledgee being
converted to an organ donor is
probably very less compared
to that person being
an influencer.
So, if you talk about
influencer marketing probably if
he knows he can directly
influence somebody
in the community.
So, this is where again
the Facebook marketing,
etc., can come into the picture.
>> It is two out of 10
over here in India.
I spoke to a lady in Spain,
which is the highest platform,
the benchmark of organ donation
right now in the world,
they have 70, 70 percent
conversion rate
from a brain-dead actually
happening to an organ
donation happening,
and here it is only 20.
So, this is the mismatch and
the disparity between what
we are here today to talk about.
>> Thank you guys. One more
question, quickly? Yeah?
>> So, I was just going
to ask what about
other countries and you
just mentioned 70 percent.
So, do they study
different textbooks in MBPS?
>> Croatia, World Cup, football?
Croatia has now jumped
from 10 to two.
See the MBPS syllabus as per
the textbooks are concerned
is across the globe
it's the same.
The only thing is
that how fast we take
signs and updates
into our portfolio.
Maybe India, it's taking
a little bit of more time,
it's a vast country,
extremely diverse.
Every 20 kilometers you
go, the language changes.
So, it has a lot
of thing into it,
but in Spain, they
have a opt-out system.
Somebody taking birth in
Spain is already
considered to be in,
unless and until at the deathbed,
the nearer kin say,
that no, I opt-out.
>> No, I was most asking
because you said people do not,
I'm not sure whether to declare
somebody as brain-dead
or not, the doctors.
So, that sounds weird to me
because there should
be a protocol and
people should be just
following that protocol.
>> Sir, there is already a law.
Every hospital at
the end of the month
should report how many
number of brain deaths
actually occurred.
But, in India there is always
passing away from
this rear door to that window.
>> In India, has a state subject,
it's not a sentence subject.
So, that is why
different states out
of the 30 plus states only
12 states right now
enrolled into the brain
[inaudible] donation program.
So, we're actually
taking about increasing
the donation rate in those states
itself and being more specific
about this Spain thing.
In Spain, I think
every hospital has
got its own grief console unit,
its own organ donation
declaration unit.
So, that is how
the whole hospital,
as a whole, is
actually trying to get
this cause moving forward
compared to India.
>> We have this model in
PGIMER Chandigarh, all of this.
>> So, thank you very much guys.
>> Thank you.
>> Pleasure having you here.